he said you know the entitlement is
almost installed in you from a young
girl you're a princess you deserve this
so when you don't get it past 25 the
entitlement is already a part of you so
touch whatever age but so is this
supposed Prince Charming that we've
raised her if we have a son are we
raising him to be the perfect gentleman
that we expect for someone's daughter
but women don't reward Prince charmings
they don't they don't women do not
reward good behavior in general I I
would say if women did reward good
behavior and chivalry then you would see
more of it because men will do anything
to get sex but if we don't reward it how
can we be mad when they don't do it